ja meine Lieben,
reden wir heute mal über die ganzen verrückten grüne
Politiker quer durch Europa.
beginnen wir bei meinem lieblingsbeispiel für
politiersinn aller grün,
nämlich mit der Frau berbock in Deutschland
die schrägste
und meine Sachen sind auch aufgrund von Unwissenheit
gefährlichste Außenministerin
die es auf dieser Welt jemals
gegeben hat, denn sie kann kein Englisch,
erklärt ganz nebenbei
als würde sie eine wurstzimmel kaufen gehen
Russland den Krieg
und meldet sogar in diesem Zusammenhang,
dass ich in Ukraine nur etwas verändern werde,
wenn sich buddin mit seiner Politik um 360 grad drehe.
das heißt egal in welchem Bereich man hineinzieht,
die verberg steht neben sich und das ist gefährlich
in der Politik.
aber wir haben in Österreich
das Kondom für diese schrägen Dame in Deutschland
und das ist unsere grüne Bundesministerin für Verkehr,
Infrastruktur,
Klimaschutz und sonstige
Problemstellungen im gewerzland.
geberslei, die grüne geberslei,
die rechte Hand des grüner witzekanzlers Kogler
die Olle sammt nach NS m 10 herum,
wie kann man der Bevölkerung das Leben
möglichst schwer machen.
und diese Dame hat heute am weltfrauntag
äh eine weitere isincidee gehabt,
neben den ganzen Belastungen durch C.
O. 2 Steuer und sonstigen blödsinnigkeiten.
ist dir jetzt eingefallen, dass bei Bewerbungen
in Unternehmen die ihre ministerung unterstehen
nun mehr jene Männer zur Bevorzugung sind,
die die jetzt heute durch fest sich als Frau fühlen?
richtig gehört?
ja das ist kein schlechter vorgezogener Aprilscherz,
das ist grüner Ernst
und das müsste wachröteln. das ist 1
ganz klarer Einblick in diese. grüne Blase,
so manchen, ja was soll ich,
alle grüner Politiker
quer durch Europa und auch anderer linker zeitgeister,
die ihnen folgen.
und ich sag euch,
das ist Motivation genug,
um in der Politik genau gegen solche große
Entwicklungen anzukämpfen.
das hätten wir sonst keine Probleme,
das hätte die Bevölkerung sonst keine Probleme.
aber die grönern
kümmern sich um einen derartigen Mist und vergessen
dabei auf die Wahlen
Sorgen der eigenen Bevölkerung.
und wir wissen das,
ihr wisst das,
ich weiß das
und das werden wir bei der nächsten Wahlen ändern.